la page culture se poursuit en ce
mercredi 3 avril nous avons deux invités
sur ce plateau on va regarder un peu de
suspense encore on parle d'un concert à
voisins le bretonneux dans un instant
avec vous auparavant l'autre actualité
culture du jour c'est la réouverture
on l'attendait plus du ciné c'est
tellement con et oui enfin les sims est
à ouvert ses portes cet après midi nous
avons rencontré les premiers spectateurs
on va écouter leurs réactions à signer
cette île en cours amiens ouvert ses
portes au public ce mercredi 3 avril 18
mois de travaux auront finalement permis
au cinéma d'être entièrement rénové
le public a pu découvrir des écrans plus
larges de nouveaux fauteuils un accès
aux trois niveaux par l'ascenseur et
enfin une troisième salle qu'en pense
alors les spectateurs à la sortie des
toutes premières séances
depuis le temps qu'on attendait ça
commence à être long voilà mais je
trouve que c'est très bien qu'on est
bien installé on a de la plaph voilà on
est content au niveau du son il est
parfait au niveau du film
et puis l'accueil et jolie là maintenant
ça change un petit peu quoi d'abord chez
c'est très beau chez spacieuse c'est
glee c'est non non c'est très agréable
très avancé je suis contente d'avoir été
une des premières à l'inaugurer moi qui
adore le cinéma un cinéma de proximité
qui a les allures d'un grand seule la
politique tarifaire reste inchangé 6
euros le billet plein tarif ou voilà
enfin ouvert ce ciné c'était long cours
ce qui fera plaisir à son directeur le
bon camp qu'on salue qui est venue
nombreuse fois sur ce plateau ça y est
il a enfin son cinéma faille est soulagé
c'est ouvert alors nous quittons
elancourt pour rejoindre voisin voisins
le bretonneux
on va se tenir samedi un concert un
concert dont l'intitulé nous donne
quelques quelques idées en tout cas des
peut-être des artistes présents
puisqu'il s'agit d'un concert intitulé
passe le message à tous voisins
alors pour en parler ce soir audrey cbi
bonsoir vous êtes chargé de
communication pour l'association en mets
ta sauce et vous allez donc que nous
expliquer quel est votre rôle
mais également ce soir bonsoir
aso vous êtes un artiste qui sera
présent sur scène samedi et vous nous
expliquerez également votre parcours et
puis comment va se composer cette mise
en scène
voilà alors tout d'abord où audrey cbi
quel a été votre rôle dans
l'organisation de ce concert
ben en fait ce concert c'est avant tout
une coréalisation entre donc nous met
asos et au ces sondes dont fait partie
sikasso qui est une autre associé qui
est une autre association voilà tous ces
deux associations se sont alliés pour
faire ce concert le 6 avril prochain
alors on va peut-être révélé le suspense
puisque dans passe le message à tous
voisins évidemment jeu de mot avec passe
le message à ton voisin
donc ton avis clairement est en scène
finit en tête d'affiche exactement alors
du coup je me tourne vers vous qu'à
sommet avant que vous nous parler de
votre lien avec ton avis de peut-être
pour mieux vous connaître vous faites du
reggae et depuis combien de temps ça
fait pas ça fait dix ans ça fait dix ans
à fond j'ai commencé à vendre après
j'avais 13 ans ensuite j'ai arrêté j'ai
attellera bombages et j'arrête elle a un
peu quelques années que vous allez
ensuite je fais d'autres choses
vous habitez billancourt en cours depuis
des années depuis l'âge de 9ans d'accord
alors ce qui concerne vos influences
musicales vous en parler sa force
musiciens le vent s'échappa hanks xavi
bout du pont
capelton omar les grands noms du reggae
voilà parce que sous la grande famille
du reggae il ya plusieurs autres
désignations notamment le dance hall
parce que c'est plutôt ce qui vous
concerne
ce qui me concerne pas ce que je fais du
reggae reggae dancehall on va dire que
j'ai des titres qui sont reggae
dancehall quand on dit d'une sauce jack
ce sont plus des types qui bouge un peu
plus
est ce que ça veut dire quelle est la
différence la différence c'est qu'une
règle et on va dire ni musicalement ce
un peu plus posé que le pinceau quoi
soulever un peu plus un peu plus jeune
quoi c'est un peu plus hélas pour le
concert qui aura donc la
voisins-le-bretonneux ça sera d'un sol
les deux ce sera les deux parce que
forcément une artiste crédit à des
morceaux dance hall et vice versa fredo
sur scène on prend les deux sur ceux et
donc sur scène justement pouvoir venir
donc on a évoqué tonton david il y aura
également king le job
voilà tout à fait donc c'est une réunion
entre amis c'est d'une autre amie puis
bon c'est d'eux que ces deux anciens
deux anciens base du mouvement reggae en
france en est folle de dieu qui fait
partie des premiers à vente autour de la
vie de même fait partie des précurseurs
à part ceux qui ont amené le reggae ici
en france donc ça nous tenait à coeur
enfin ça me tenait à coeur d'avoir
à voir ces deux là ensemble sur tous les
plateaux vous avez réussi à les mettre
d'accord sur une taxe alors nous avons
eu ce matin par téléphone quand on la
vide qui nous a parlé de votre rencontre
à tous les deux on va l'écouter confère
et puis avec mon père qui était présent
il parlait avec cateau puis le lendemain
j'ai vu tu fais la musique
il faut qu avec diva fait honneur qui
les fait rêver bien plus des couilles
l'application et puis effectivement mars
ça a bien collé depuis le 9 contre les 2
3 des droits de concession depuis nantes
mais lourdement contre il fait partie
rencontré william dafoe et ses coups de
téléphone
tentons à vide qui vous appelle comment
est-ce que manquant tonton david vos
contacts comme ça après avoir échangé
comme l'expliqué cette ronde bas la
première fois qu'il m'a appelé voit
souvent ça fait bizarre parce que on n'a
pas l'habitude 1 j'avais un pote
s'appelait david donc moi je pensais que
c'était lui c'est que finalement tu
finale
rencontre que c'est au tour david donc
on a mis ensuite grâce à son père dans
ce sens hier à détecter chez vous moi
c'est parce qu'elles étaient plus
franches et que ce soit là on a passé
une bonne soirée ensemble vraiment la
merde et qu'après cinq noms à la suite
de la conversation j'ai su que c'était
son père ah oui vous saviez pas un bon
début au début on attend ton avis nous a
également décrit un petit peu ce qui
allait représenter pour lui ce concert
donc on va l'écouter également les
commentaires mais je vais bien plaisir
parce que j'ai quelques vols qui vont
emmener on devrait passer une bonne
soirée sans pression parce que c'est
franck repop surtout comme je connais
beaucoup de monde dans les 170 la place
en prévente
elle est à 8 euros elle est pas cher que
j'ai pas des fois qu'ils viennent à
l'entrée rire dieu tient chez moi ça
fait longtemps que je t'ai pas vu il me
retrouvera tu chacun père à sa place ça
va rassurer les organisateurs aussi
forcément voilà donc on aviez compris la
place en pré vente s'est vite euros
c'est ça vous confirmez d'accord alors
bon ballon maintenant on envie d'avoir
une idée peut-être de ce que va être ce
concert et on a la chance d'avoir un
teaser pas qu'on va pouvoir regarder
chacun son chemin chacun son rêve j'ai
regardé
chacun sa route chacun son chemin
passez message à ton voisin
les gens dedans et déjà les gens tombent
maintenant si j'ai pas région à l'autre
et je les vois bien jusqu'à maintenant
et jusqu'à ses les bleus
les blindés allemands
j'ai habité des années
c'est plus
et c'est maintenant que j'habite
homogène que je veux que tu résumer
c'est parce que ces gars sont salées
conseiller toussaint
ce qui
kasso vous avez également un album je
crois qu'il est en préparation
je prépare un album dont la sortie est
prévue fin 2013
d'ailleurs j'ai un single maquis qui
n'était fini qui est presque finie
puisque la sortie officielle c'est fin
avril a défini sauf qu'il est pas encore
sorti sur qui feint il de 30 en une
vous avez la générosité de nous de nous
donner pour une exclusivité ce soir
alors on va les côtés aussi
cependant toutes les radios
la loi des hommes
enfin
m
donc ce single s'appelle fois dure cette
guerre
en clair c'est pour cueillir le banc
clair c'est pour les femmes ont donc
vous aimez ce type de femme parce que ça
le moment se joue des sens est en deuil
à ce type de frein un hommage c'est
parfait est donc cet album donc sorti
fin fin d'année on retrouve quel type
pareil là de musique il va s'appeler de
paris à maurice là aussi un clin d'oeil
à vos origines
bonjour la maison de devoir trouver un
peu de tout du dancehall comme
maintenant il va moi aussi du reggae
quelques featurings aperçu de cet album
sur scène je me trompe mais celui que
vous avez entendu en tête un mode single
qui sortira bientôt et ce sera tout pour
l'instant comment se portent les
réservations pour l'instant sur cette
date
c'est un concert attendez moi pour te
dis ça commence à bien venir
alors on rappelle la date parce que
c'est samedi le 16 avril louis donc
c'est à la salle de la tour espace de
covile à voisins donc à nouveau les
numéros de téléphone pour réserver
on souhaite un public très nombreux pour
venir vous voir
et puis salué un petit peu le retour
comme de ton avis sur la scène des
divines ce sens merci à tous les deux
mercier original également on retrouve
mercredi prochain pour une nouvelle page
culture merci de nous avoir suivi sur tv
films nouvelle édition du 7 8 à 18
heures demain
parmi nos invités notamment gérard
larcher sénateur maire ump de
rambouillet puisque s'ouvre est l'examen
au sénat du projet de loi autorisant le
mariage pour les personnes de même sexe
gérard larcher a été le président du
sénat pendant quatre ans excellente
soirée et à demain